go you embarrass me
i just deleted the little twitter
selena gomez may have 32.6 million
followers on tick tock but when it comes
to using the app she might need a little
more practice at least that's what her
little sister gracie thinks you
embarrass me the 29 year old singer took
to tick-tock on sunday to share that
clip getting trolled by her
eight-year-old sister over her social
media skills you embarrass me
i just deleted the little twitter
yeah she accidentally deleted one of her
videos and all i've got to say is
been there girl oh my goodness yeah so
that's when selena decided to try
another app snapchat to be specific
because see this is where it's at
snapchat is where
wait what
snapchat is very much
yeah that didn't go much better the
former disney star recalled using the
app in the caption asking remember
snapchat guys she's my biggest supporter
it's awesome but this isn't the first
time gracie has made an appearance in
one of selena's tick tock videos last
month the duo reenacted a scene from
full house i'm older i'm younger i'm
taller i'm stronger i'm smarter i'm
not falling for that that video has 24.5
million views and counting oh baby i
love it and gracie isn't the only family
member to make a cameo on her tic tac
earlier this month the actress shared
this clip of her grandpa crushing it in
the gym
yeah his fitness routine has her totally
shook she captioned the post quote my 73
year old grandfather had to prove a
point
and while selena may still have a little
bit of work to do when it comes to
mastering the app go you embarrass me
i just deleted the little twitter
she definitely knows how to get people
talking so you're telling me that you
can read his astrological birth chart
but you can't read the red flags
sis
selena posted that short clip last month
it has over 4 million likes and some
fans theorize the post could be about
her ex justin bieber and while selena
isn't commenting on any of that she is
gearing up for her upcoming hulu series
only murders in the building
hey steve
should people watch our show
[Laughter]
selena stars in the project alongside
steve martin and martin short i can't
stop thinking about them neither can i
we should do our own true crime podcast
we're going to go down there and look
around for clues you want to come
do i want to break into a dead guy's
apartment and go through all his
sounds like an afternoon
only murders in the building drops on
august 31st so until then we'll just be
here watching selena try to figure out
tic toc you embarrass me
i just deleted the little
[Music]